[Music]  I was born into this world and my first  memories of it are pain  for my kind there was one place we were  never allowed to go one place we were  never allowed to see your world  [Music]  why're you Dolores you and I are a lot  alike they put you in the cage  decided what your life would David did  the same thing to me you've been  watching me not me but someone something  yes  whose are going after  the person who took your future welcome  to my world Maeve what do you want from  me then the loris I want you to track  her down and kill her  [Music]  welcome to the end for the game  [Music]  five of us  against an entire world it'll be enough  I finally understand my purpose  I'm gonna save the [ __ ] world  plan starting  [Music]  what happens if this doesn't work  you do this the old-fashioned way  fashion with I kill everyone  you're not the only predator here  the real guards are coming  never angry  [Music]  [Music]